this is Rob handle Reno hi I'm Andy
Bauman hey we've got Far Cry primal up
here in the big window oh yeah and we
wanted to show you some things now Rob I
hear you're a piece master I am just any
piece master you like to ride them hard
dude I will ride them all day auntie
bellman uh there are some interesting
things about riding beasts that I highly
recommend there is any tip I could give
anyone who is starting off with this
game is get the saber-toothed tiger now
how do we get it cuz so far I've
unlocked cats and wolves right you know
controlling tame but I don't think I can
get the saber-tooth now do we have to
unlock a skill to get that or like
what's the deal there so the deal with
that is and we will take a look here is
so you got at some point in the game you
will have the option to basically start
rescuing all these different specialists
there are two that you definitely want
to go for first
I like highly recommend you do it and
they are one of the first ones you just
kind of like to do is uh Tensei so he
will basically no obviously he's the
Beastmaster he will get you you know
fairly far and then the other guy is ass
dude name of kaduche and he's kind of
like just just this overall badass
soldier dude he's got one perk that is
the rider and there it is get that so
yeah you're gonna saw off this game
you're gonna be like alright ward I put
these skills what I recommend you do is
just honestly as much lady bump save
your points because I know a couple of
these require like three skill points
yeah as you progress down the line
higher up here right just get the
saber-toothed tiger it's amazing now
hope your stated - yeah so the only
problem actually is with the saber-tooth
is that he will drowned in water and you
get like oh yeah excellent kill you
can't afford that River with this able
to you know and yeah I killed him by
accident recom hard lesson thing
I'm so cool I wish I had in love with
this time seriously I really am in love
with it so get a load of this so you
thought the bear was fast
this dude is so much faster any frolics
look at this I mean oh yeah just go
Mahlum so you can attack while on the
back and he attacks and so like you
shoot stuff and you just claws and bites
yeah he claws bites and you'll help
he'll scare lesser animals which is
always nice like apex predator yeah the
I mean this guy is badass and so just in
general I mean this goes for any animal
well another really great like you want
to be able to get to this point like
ASAP and there's a really strong reason
for that is scavenging if you as you
know like you go up to things on foot
and there's an animation not on the
animal it's like instant life hacks huh
yeah like you're just if you know you're
gonna be scavenging them you're gonna be
scavenging all the time but later this
is just like so much fast oh look a
you're always getting wood like there's
a dog but they all see he's out he's out
yeah that's a really good point dude
like I'm always looking for the hard
wood the hardwood they have to collect
for your weapons cuz basically like the
ammo of the game right yeah as everyone
will learn as they start plays game and
it yeah you kind of have to bend down
and chop it think about all the time
you're saving by just going by yeah
flying by it
yeah like think leggett like late game
you know you're gonna be doing this
constantly and to get this out of the
way and just seriously like people start
off the game just work for it get to
this point and I swear to god it's just
so worth it and also it's a
saber-toothed tiger I mean it's on the
cover of the game you know you're riding
this freakin thing there details how is
the cover athlete of Cry primal 2015
dude under 16 yeah on Rose M so he's
definitely worth your time I hear you
yeah these are some hot tips from Rob
Hanbury love it thank so much you like I
definitely SPECT a different way in the
skill tree and there's like certainly
other ways you could go but I think you
convinced me with the saber-tooth and
just getting the rideable beast mm-hmm
Berk or whatever it's called is like yep
do that no that's a nice suit
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]